yeah hold on to your waffles today
everybody we got more wind coming in
fact this palm tree was
just blowing around real good here just
a second ago
you can still see that the fronds are
moving around in the breeze we've got
cloudy skies to start your thursday
and southwest winds that are already
starting to pick up especially out on
the west side
red rock has been pretty breezy through
the early morning hours
south valley neighborhoods are picking
up some of that wind look at all the 50s
this morning with those clouds
holding in some of that warmth 34 but
kyle canyon a little cooler perhaps at
50. you've been having some breezes as
well
52 in mesquite 34 up in caliani looking
for some showers today
snow showers tonight and tomorrow 50 in
searchlight 52 in laughlin
kingman at 46. so we're going to look
for the chance of
rain tonight but through the day we'll
have
clouds and then maybe some sunshine
through the afternoon
southwest winds building up speed 25 30
miles an hour that chance of showers
comes tonight and early tomorrow morning
with some snow again in the mountains
and then we're off to a warmer nice
sunny weekend
well we're getting 70's maybe even some
low 80's back as soon as sunday
this system is diving into the southwest
spreading rain and snow across the
intermountain west
and we are already seeing some snow
returns up here in lincoln county and
southwest utah
but again it looks like we might get a
few breaks of some sun through the
afternoon
and then the bulk of that system comes
through tonight with showers there are
wind advisories kind of around us mohave
county
san bernardino counties have wind
advisories starting later this morning
into this evening but nothing issued for
clark county still
i think we're looking at about 30 mile
an hour winds this afternoon
early clouds some afternoon clearing
highs in the upper 60s
with those gusty winds and then that
chance of showers tonight
into early friday morning before this
system scoots out
we'll get some northwest winds overnight
as well
and then some afternoon sunshine mid 60s
tomorrow
mid to upper 70s for our last weekend of
march even 80s on monday
and then breezy and back to 70s next
week as we
head towards april